es el doble discurso de irán desde la
cancillería hablan de apertura para
lograr un nuevo acuerdo nuclear
saldremos hacia viena con un equipo
completo y una voluntad seria de
levantar las sanciones
mientras su responsable del programa de
energía nuclear promete seguir buscando
enriquecer uranio para conseguir una
arma atómica
lo importante es que irán está decidido
a continuar con su programa nuclear y
quiere utilizar todos los aspectos para
mejorar la vida de su nación
la crisis empezó en 2018
donald trump retiró a eeuu del pacto
nuclear de 2015 firmado por ambas
naciones junto a rusia china francia
reino unido y alemania
entonces irán empezó a incumplir sus
acuerdos y ahora para recuperar un pacto
que incluye a eeuu pide levantar todas
las sanciones incluidas las que no
tienen que ver con su programa nuclear
eeuu promete buscar nuevas estrategias
si vuelven a fracasar las negociaciones
serán vuestros amigos y enemigos saben
que desde eeuu podemos desplegar una
fuerza abrumadora en el momento y lugar
que elijan es
el máximo enemigo de irán también está
expectante israel siempre se ha puesto a
un acuerdo así hablaban en 2015
el mundo es un lugar mucho más peligroso
hoy que ayer
pensaba lo mismo el ministro de defensa
de israel en el momento del acuerdo
moshe yalon hoy lo ve diferente la
retirada de eeuu ha resultado ser el
principal error en la región de la
última década ahora están más cerca que
nunca de convertirse en un estado
nuclear ambigüedad mientras la
diplomacia internacional acelera las
negociaciones para que después de seis
rondas de conversaciones por fin se
alcance un pacto